aber was ich meine wirklich das würde
doch nie und nimmer jemand was von einem
südkoreanischen musiker mitbekommen was
das einfach ich finde das habe ich das
richtig kulturelle vielfalt luca ich
wollte das fachwort nennt kulturelle
vielfalt entsteht dadurch und das ist
eigentlich in 99 prozent aller fälle
immer was positives weswegen das sehr
sehr schade traurig und menschheits
vergewaltigt und wäre wenn das internet
wirklich für immer weg wäre
hey leute in herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen kontrakt heute zusammen mit
the code wurst song hey hey mein pony
schön dass du mich hier eingeladen hat
sich fotografisch code crafter und kot
wurst sohn am start immer kontakt
zusammen wo kontakt noch mal wo ich
immer so themen raus suche wo ich dann
mit anderen leuten darüber quatsch heute
reden über das thema was wäre wenn das
internet auf einmal komplett weg wäre
mit hedos und mit tape am start
und was carlos denkt dass er mich grad
ist natürlich gerade schon stundenlang
gedanken darüber gemacht
damit ergänzen jahre jahre ja - das wäre
wirklich seit unserer geburt diese
produkte erhalten es ist einfach so da
braucht jetzt noch gar nicht lachen da
brauche ich jetzt auch gar nicht lachen
ich weiß gar nicht warum ich gerade
mache aber es ist ein wasser darauf
treffen
während ich ja auch schon wäre ich jetzt
ein schluck trinken kann kein chaos ja
schon mal anfangen was er davon hält was
er denkt was wäre wenn das internet
jetzt auf einmal weg werde wenn
natürlich unser anruf weg aber was wäre
dann würde denn sonst noch alles
passieren die pakete am ende sind keine
fans mehr am start und wir haben ganz
viele menschen die sie gucken müssen die
sich am tag irgendwie einen runterholen
ohne fixe vorlage das ist der witz
gewesen an sich aber nie wenn das
internet weg ist dass man sich wirklich
mal vorstellen da hängt so verdammt viel
dran also zum einmal die ganze
wirtschaft wir haben zum beispiel amazon
als riesigen online händler als als
möglich indem wirtschaftskraft ohne ende
das wirklich so wenn man das den pimmel
größen nehmen würde dann wäre das der
eiffelturm
das ist wirklich richtig richtig dicken
ansonsten schwer alles darüber nicht
dass sie dich zu wort kommen das ist
jetzt mein video conny gerät er immer
war
es hängt einfach unglaublich viel
zusammen das sind nicht nur
internetseiten wieder am ende weg sind
sondern einfach kommunikation geht am
arsch börse geht am arsch
wirtschaft geht am arsch politik geht am
arsch paulus kita marian asch die suppe
die politik uns doch eigentlich dann
aufgefordert zu handeln bei so was rein
theoretisch ja ich meine mit politik
meine gar solche sachen wie sowas so
dieses dieses also politik hat ja das
internet inzwischen schon als medium für
sich entdeckte sie auch wieder damit
sich meinung bildet ja zum beispiel die
koalition soll glaube ich auch jetzt
übers internet gewählt werden habe ich
gehört also die werden auf jeden fall
internet wird mehr oder weniger immer
mehr an gekannt auch anerkannt auch
marketingmäßig natürlich die ganze
unternehmen wollte immer mehr ins
internet gehen das ist aber ein komplett
anderes thema das zum beispiel auch
unternehmen wie was war das denn
ja das habe ich ja schon gesagt mit der
koalition jetzt auch übers internet
gewählt werden soll damit er auch mehr
jüngere leute natürlich an den start
kommen allerdings wenn das internet weg
wer was natürlich für sich erstmal
eigentlich gar nicht passieren könnte da
es geht einfach nicht ist kann nicht weg
da braucht man keine begründung jetzt
kann nicht einfach weggehen ist das ist
wahr dass das kann ich seine findet es
so verletzt und überall auf der welt
stehen server und kabel verlegt und
alles möglich ist kann nicht sein aber
wenn das internet auf einmal weg wäre
wenn wir natürlich alle komplett
abgeschottet voneinander ich meine diese
ganzen geschäftstermine die alle über
über e mails laufen geht die komplette
planung der weg und was halt wirklich
der größte faktor wer was der größte
verlust wäre mehr oder weniger wert wäre
ja mehr oder weniger die wirtschaft
wieder ganz schön dass die börse hängt
ja alles vom internet ab diese ganzen
kurse et cetera das wird ja gar nicht
auf diese ganzen werden der ganzen
wertpapierhandel mit ja gar nicht
funktionieren wenn da kein internet am
start wäre deswegen die kompletten kurse
würden den eimer gehen und die ganze
unternehmen pleite geht nicht nur amazon
amazon sondern auch was hatte ich ja
gerade mal ein beispiel
allgemeines kugel wie viele unternehmen
schalten mittlerweile google adsense
werbung
das ist so krank und das wird alles
einfach den eimer runtergeht und ich
weiß gar nicht wie würdest du zum
beispiel ergeben wenn jetzt auf einmal
das internet beck wer was wird als
erstes machen
also weg war das schon öfters ehrlich
gesagt das geht ein kompletter die würde
man reagieren also wenn man wirklich
merkt irgendwie das ist nach einem tag
nicht wieder da und ist einfach weltweit
ausgefallen
auf unbestimmte zeit also mir würde ich
würde viel mehr freizeit haben eindeutig
weil man natürlich als als youtube mega
viel rein steckt das heißt ich hätte
wahrscheinlich mega viel langeweile und
bist du nicht wirklich was damit
anfangen
wahrscheinlich würde ich mir leider
fotos von dir ausdrucken und das geht ja
auch nicht mehr guck da siehst du dir
schon die erste alternative die mir
einfällt geht auch nicht keine fotos für
die austria
ja das ist das ist so eine sache also
ich glaube so für einen moment sogar ich
finde das sollst als experiment genau
als experiment finde ich das sogar ganz
cool aber das kannst du nicht auf die
ganze welt beziehen weil wie gesagt
hängt einfach so viel wirtschaftskraft
und seriöser schild dran aber was was
würde man das ist vielleicht auch so
eine frage für die kommentare
finde ja schreibt meine kommentare was
wie würdet ihr reagieren und was würdet
ihr dann machen wenn das internet wäre
also ihr könnt natürlich auch schreiben
was ihr denkt was allgemeinen
weltpolitisch beziehungsweise
weltwirtschaftlich passieren würde das
wäre natürlich doppelt interessant dass
jeder denkt das wird einfach alles den
bach runtergehen das muss man einfach
sagen wer das ist genauso wie wenn ihr
links gehackt wird ging jetzt beispiel
ja ok weither gegriffen aber snowden zum
beispiel der da informationen offenbart
hat das wäre natürlich das hat für ein
riesen skandal gesorgt und da sind
einfach nur informationen offengelegt
worden allerdings wenn diese ganze
informationen einfach weg sind und ich
meine was was läuft denn noch alles über
das internet läuft es läuft einfach
alles mittlerweile über das internet
allein stell dir vor die ganzen server
bin einfach crashen alle dateien werden
weg stellte das mal vor die ganzen datei
die im internet gesammelt werden die
ganzen e mails die ganzen youtube-kanäle
die ganzen facebook-profile alles wäre
weg mehr oder weniger komplett online
banking alles doch einfach was die
informationsfreiheit angeht und das was
die nachrichten muss ja bedenken so eine
zeitung was ja viele immer noch lesen
aber das ist eine sache die seine zeit
braucht du kriegst ja wirklich durch das
internet
kriegst du quasi in echtzeit fast alles
mit was auf der welt passiert das heißt
wenn irgendwo krieg ausbricht dann hat
man das durch das internet innerhalb von
drei sekunden ich denke das wird man
auch irgendwann mitbekommen wenn wenn
wenn es das internet nicht da wäre aber
wirklich zu diese ganzen diese ganzen
sachen wo man vielleicht sich dann auch
selbst engagiert wo man vielleicht mal
angenommen ist passiert irgendeine
katastrophe in einem teil von
deutschland und es ist wirklich so dass
das die leute spenden sollten damit dass
alles funktioniert und so weiter und so
fort spendenaufrufe charity-aktion alles
drum und dran
damit ihr so viel über das internet
gemacht an sich und das würde sich gar
nicht mehr anders realisieren lassen
glaubt ja oder allgemein teams ganz
schnell wechselt diese ganze
informationsverbreitung wieder grad
schon sagt dass wenn irgendwo ein krieg
ausbricht die ganzen zeitungen beispiel
axel springer verlag bild die kriegen
das ja alles erst mit täglich gerade die
bildrate die kriegen das erste mal was
für die ganze zeit lief der schlingel du
hesch nordmann ihm ein lebendes bild
gekauft außerdem modena drin statt die
ganz kostenlos ich stehe auch bald in
der computer bild zumindest zitate von
mir bezüglich tritt tv das auf service
ist auch ein bild von dir drin dann habe
ich dieses jahr da ist auch ein bild von
mir drinnen alles klar
ziemlich kommt glaube ich november aber
kauft es nicht das bild nein gut ist ein
anderes thema aber die kriegen das ja
auch alles nur bei internet mit das
heißt die komplette bild würde die
komplett den keller runtergehen ich
meine
stellt euch das vor ich kriege so viel
mit in meinem kompletten leben durch das
allein das wird total iran aber durch
das leiden von der seite n tv n24
die welt spiegel online faz auf twitter
und also folgen auf twitter und auf
facebook und allgemein weil ich hier
immer startseite n-tv habe und hier auf
meinem handy übrigens mit einer
wunderschönen lego hülle gab meine fans
kämen gepumpt krieg ich halt immer
wirklich gebremst jetzt er ich habe eine
app die heizung clean news und da kriege
ich immer oben sondern banner hier oben
rein so club und da werden wir den news
angezeigt da habe ich zum beispiel heute
nachmittag als die autouni kamen gelesen
audio schon wieder amoklauf usa oder so
dass es hätte zum beispiel dadurch nicht
mitbekommen wenn das internet weg wäre
dann hätte ich das ein komplett nicht
mitbekommen oder allgemein diese ganze
unterhaltungen mittlerweile zum beispiel
auch nachrichten basieren mittlerweile
bei apple auf dem internet
imessage mehr oder weniger und allgemein
facebook stell dir vor die ganzen daten
werden einfach weg ich meine ein seite
der es gut aber auf der anderen seite
was facebook dadurch eine riesige pleite
machen würde diese ganzen arbeitsstellen
arbeitsplätze die dadurch verloren gehen
würden wenn das internet einfach sagen
wir mal für einen monat weg werk wenn es
einfache weg wäre diese ganzen leute die
bei google arbeiten oder diese ganzen
leute die in irgendwelchen weiß ich
nicht wo die arbeiten das ist ja auch
scheißegal ich meine finger auf so viele
leute mal hinter webseiten hinter die
die website aktualisiert einfach ein tv-
online- dienst und so was alles
beispielsweise das wird ja alles da
würden ja millionen an arbeitsplätzen
weg gehen und dann werden alle
arbeitslos wetten richtig richtig
richtig hohe qualität an
arbeitslosigkeit und dagegen könnte man
ja dann auch mehr oder weniger nichts
machen deswegen wird quasi mehr oder
weniger ja ich weiß nicht was wird das
für eine massenarbeitslosigkeit auf
jeden fall zu viel viel logischer weise
nie massenarbeitslosigkeit dass das kein
cooles thema ist in dem fall dann weil
also ich finde finden fans so fasst
abseits von von den faktoren die du bist
doch genau das was am anfang klar sie
können auch ganz ganz ganz andere mit
weiterbildung noch angerissen und das
ist auch das was mir gerade erst noch so
zwischendrin so in den sinn gekommen ist
das einfach also das internet ist für
mich persönlich schon immer so ein platz
gewesen wo sich einfach extrem viele
menschen egal ist ob auf
wissenschaftlicher oder kreativer ebene
verwirklichen können das heißt da kommt
einfach sehr sehr viel zusammen da
treffen sich viele coole menschen die
gemeinsam projekte angehen vielleicht
alleine projekte machen man bekommt
interessante meinungen von allen seiten
egal ob sie einen jetzt gefallen oder
nicht dass alles wird ist also einem
riesengroßen ball so einem wollknäuel
aus aus kreativität und auch
menschlichkeit ja vor allem das internet
ist mittlerweile auch ein punkt
beziehungsweise eine plattform wo sich
halt alle möglichen leute ihre meinungen
kund geben können auch youtube unter
anderem dass wir zum beispiel unsere mal
mit unserer meinung leute beeinflussen
können oder allein über das internet hat
ja auch gesagt diese ganzen
charity-aktion beispiel zurzeit unicef
ohne color haben die glaub ich gemacht
da kann man auf der seite unicef es gibt
16,9 millionen farben auf der welt da
kann man sich einfach eine farbe kaufen
auf ohne color dot com heißt die seite
glaube ich können männer kugel die
kosten einen dollar und dieser dollar
wird halt gespendet
dort kommt so was alles das geht
mittlerweile über das internet
und deswegen das ist oder auch diese
ganzen leute ich weiß nicht wie viele
jung sagte das was oder heißt überhaupt
viele junge ich weiß es gar nicht ist
ein polit kritiker politik asmus
sarkastischer als taktiker nicht der
held auch immer so der hat bei twitter
20.000 voll oder auch nicht so viel aber
der post teilt auch immer seine meinung
bezüglich themen oder hier es gibt doch
eine heißen die ich weiß gar nicht die
ganzen namen genau aber die parodien
halten also die bild zeitung und
kritisieren die so nimmt sich täglich
ein artikel aus der bild und analysieren
den und machen den so schlecht die bild
und sowas als das sind also leute die ja
mittlerweile ihre anhänger gefunden es
gibt bestimmte seiten überall die durch
das internet entwickelt wurden die eher
gegeneinander aufgehetzt werden bzw
einfach verschiedene standpunkte ohne
das internet selbst das halt alles gar
nicht dass wer hat wirklich alles weg es
gäbe keine plattform mit der zum
beispiel leute in kontakt treten könnten
mit uns beispielsweise ich meine wir
sind mittlerweile so c promis auf
youtube also in unserer branche mehr
oder weniger kennt man uns allerdings
abseits davon nicht das halt so der
unterschied zwischen den promis die
jeder keinen ärger also ich bin z
bitte ja ich möchte dass schon die
korrekte bezeichnung haben du bist doch
ich bin ja okay gut das ist eine klasse
für sich die beiden bei anmerken
es ist noch ziemlich viel pink zu
verkaufen bei unicef kurz kurz lang ist
voll die coole aktionen wie anders das
gibt muss man noch mal schreibe ich
heute auch erfahren aber ich auf jeden
fall cool ohne solche sachen gerade eben
das dass das lässt sich halt nur über
das integrierte sind es gibt so viel
kunst die auch an dessen über das ohne
diese ganzen sachen dieses dass zum
beispiel auch es muss nicht mal was
ernstes sein es kann doch einfach sein
dass dadurch auch dinge entdeckt werden
die man einfach nur witzig finde das
internet bereitet uns täglich so viel so
viel spaß ich meine du denkt jetzt
eventuell einen anderen spaß als wir
alle
ich bin bei normalen menschen die kuchen
youtube-videos oder menschen alles klar
begabt im internet sind mit normalen
menschen
luca hat mir vorher als er mich zu
dieser aufnahme motiviert hat in
whatsapp war zu faul zu schreiben und
während er sich ausgezogen
habe ich eine mega sprachnachricht
bekommen ich wusste dass das gegenüber
rap und wird sich laut wieder zu
gewichtig mich ausziehen
aber ich glaube die hose die kritischen
los will ich den knopf effekt nehmen
also ich sag mir so gar nicht okay
stimmt das würde auf zu lügen
mein freund ich stimmt gar nicht
natürlich stimmt doch gar nicht beweisen
dass das coni wenig soll ich spiele bei
gott verlassen
okay stimmt ich bleibe dabei ich war
einfach zu faul bei sky zu schreiben und
ich bin halt echt gerade jetzt wieder
gekommen
das neurotische was ja aber ich wollte
noch erwähne ich habe auch noch nicht so
etwas gesehen so eine kunstform die sich
auch über das netz realisieren lässt das
ist ja nicht jetzt nicht nur video video
könnt ihr zum beispiel auf kassette
brennen oder so aber ich habe noch nie
etwas gesehen ich weiß nicht mehr genau
wie das ist das hat der song bay auf
twitter gepostet
das war so ein bild du konntest in dem
bild scrollen und du konntest quasi das
bild immer weiter rein und raus die
ganze zeit also das war quasi so ein
endlos sich wiederholt das bild das
heißt muss hier vorstellen einer
zeichnete schüssel und in die schüssel
zeichnet ein anderer künstler wieder
eine schüssel und dann kannst du was sie
in die schüssel rein und wieder raus
leider wird das immer so weitergehen das
bild also einfach total krassen coolen
hippen ich bin ich schon wieder schütz
sagen weil es kein schritt ist richtig
einfach interessanter so anderson
das sind so sachen das kann man
eigentlich vergleich mit der unicef
aktion obwohl es zwei komplett
verschiedene kategorien sind es in
sachen die nur über das internet möglich
sind
die nur die während vielleicht auch
möglich auf dem gameboy atwan halt jetzt
dein maul was jetzt aus allen verkommen
mannschaft jetzt einfach ausgehen
ich höre den machen es jetzt einfach am
reden aber das internet verbreiten sich
nur über das internet zum beispiel so
eine aktion wie unicef wird zum beispiel
auf facebook geteilt und über allem
dadurch erreicht dass so eine art
bekannt jetzt gerade das war zum
beispiel mit 2 und kann am style was zb
auch so wird gepostet auf facebook auf
mein geld immer geteilt geteilt geteilt
da muss nach einem diskurs abgespielt
dann war im fernsehen und alles mögliche
oder die entwicklung von
dieter braun kennst ja wahrscheinlich
hätte die kommune aber aber weiß das ist
eben so dass auch ganz und gar mir noch
ein ball ist möglich sind du musst dir
mal vorstellen ohne das internet hätte
doch nie und nimmer jemand von kaiser's
mitbekommen von dem südkoreanischen
musiker ich habe mich wohl klingt ohne
egal
aber trainer hat mir den alles was das
ist
den hatte ich orientiere mich neben
langen hast du von mir der den haben
stehen also da kann ich nicht mehr hier
aber was ich meine wirklich dass das
würde doch nie und nimmer jemand was von
einem südkoreanischen musiker
mitbekommen was das einfach ich finde es
habe ich das wirklich kulturelle
vielfalt luca ich wollte das fachwort
kulturelle vielfalt entsteht dadurch und
das ist eigentlich in 99 prozent aller
fälle immer was positives weswegen das
sehr sehr schade traurig und menschheits
vergewaltigt und wäre wenn das internet
wirklich für mehr und was jetzt auch
wahrscheinlich viele wenn das ältere
leute gucken sollten könnt ihr
eigentlich neueren eltern zeigen was wir
davon halten wenn das rad eure eltern
gehen hey was los los los los los
liebe grüße an alle eltern mögen eltern
ja klar wir mögen eltern wir mögen
lenker eltern ich habe auch ich hab auch
eltern ich weiß nicht ob sie auch eltern
haben aber eltern sind was tolles ich
habe mich natürlich aber die sache ist
dass es halt oft zu angesehen wird so
internet noch schlechter ist die ganze
jugend jemand drin
ich meine es ist ja nicht mehr der
jugend allein der dieser entwicklung des
internets net so viele unternehmen
allein durch die ganze werbung auf
youtube das die darstellt für den stand
haben ich meine natürlich so eine
werbung für viagra oder sowas klicken
jetzt nicht so leute an die auf youtube
sind dass es ein bisschen doof
durchplanen aber sowas wie zum beispiel
eine werbung für die ps4 die erreicht
bei youtube schon so eine hohe relevanz
dass es so viele leute an gucken das ist
mittlerweile das kann sich keiner
vorstellen oder so viele leute die sie
einfach eine gute internetpräsenz
aufbauen
es gibt zum beispiel die adidas modeshow
für die trikots für die wm 2014 von der
deutschen fußball nationalmannschaft
wird nur noch über das internet über den
livestream stattfinden und nicht mehr in
echt weil einfach diese zielgruppe von
adidas 14 bis 19 jährigen sind und die
gehen nicht auf seine modenschau die
gucken sich das im internet an und
passte dann schalten sie da ein bisschen
wir haben dann haben
von mehr als 9 sondern als besondere
modenschau deswegen also es wird so viel
einfach untergehen allgemein einfach man
muss einfach nur sagen börse einfach nur
wirtschaft new yorks steht er die börse
und frankfurt auch und das ist alles ist
wird diese so dermaßen bach runtergehen
ganz unternehmen und kein
wertpapierhandel mehr und aktienkäufe
das war auch so ein bisschen aus allen
teilen man lieber luca jetzt meint hier
einmal wasser geraten sprachlichen
hänger deswegen dachte ich mir das haben
wir jetzt jetzt jetzt kommt nämlich eure
sache das war ein toller toller
zusammenfassung ja allgemein jetzt auch
wie könnte ich jetzt wieder anfangen von
jahr zwischenmenschliche beziehungen wie
viele leute arbeiten auch über das
internet und sind selbstständig und
verkaufen zum beispiel maschinen und
verkaufen maschinen dieses kaufen für
den halben preis und kaufen verkaufen
zum doppelten preis dieses prinzip
machen ihr mittlerweile so viele leute
maschinenbauingenieure und kaufmänner
und alles mögliche das ist ganz einfach
oder
diese ganzen oldtimer käufer oder so das
als wertpapier man ja quasi hat als
einen gewissen wert der hat nicht an
wert verliert zu mehr gewalt wie weiß
was meine das läuft mittlerweile alles
übers internet deswegen wird das wird
alles nicht mehr
das wird nicht mehr alles funktioniert
also ist die komplette welt wird
einbrechen ohne internet ist
mittlerweile einfach so deswegen sollte
internet nicht abgestempelt werden ach
das hat keine sowieso keine zukunft in
zukunft wird alles auf das internet
aufgebaut sein bzw ist schon mehr oder
weniger und man sieht seine entwicklung
so
es vertrage stand verloren geht das war
auf jeden fall ach mensch der morgens
schon direkt morgen
zwischen her wer zwischen herbert und
eos 2.0 sollte wenn es euch gefallen die
gleiche meinung wie wir dann gebt bitte
einen daumen hoch und ihr könnt uns auch
in die kommentare schreiben worüber wir
uns sehr freuen würden was ihr dazu
denkt was wird denkt ihr seid ihr
unserer meinung oder wer anderer meinung
die respektieren natürlich eure meinung
ist in der beschreibung hier sollte
bitte alle nicht abonnieren weil der
macht total cup videos und einfach nicht
auf dem kanal vorbeigucken gemacht auch
nicht minecraft hero und der ist auch
nicht in der ersten folge stimmt mit mir
gestorben
und dann würde ich sagen dann kann dich
geh doch müssten abgefuckte schütze